Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 110 und mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Ich begrüße euch zu dieser Notruf-Ausgabe und vielleicht hätte man hier heute mal was über die Polizei machen sollen, aber dazu ist es nicht gekommen. Allerdings haben wir einen anderen Notruf hier am Start, darauf werden wir im Laufe der Sendung noch zu sprechen kommen, denn heute soll es ein weiteres Mal gehen um Telefonnetze, was ja auch schon das Thema in der letzten Sendung war. Da ging es allerdings eher um die Computer- und Telefonieintegration, sprich, wie kann man mit dem Computer an das Sprachtelefonnetz ran, um so zu tun, als wäre man selber jemand, der rumtelefoniert. Das ist heute nicht das Ding, sondern tatsächlich ist diese Sendung eine Art Follow-Up-Sendung auf eine Sendung, die mit der Nummer 40 hier schon mal gelaufen ist, digitale Telefonnetze. Und damals wie heute begrüße ich Tobias Engel bei Chaosradio Express. Ja, letztes Mal haben wir schon ausführlich gesprochen und ich habe auch gerade selber noch mal ein bisschen durch die Sendung durchgeblättert und festgestellt, es ging dann doch weniger um die Netze als solche, sondern vielmehr darüber, wie man auf diese Netzwerke zugreift, also wie man daran teilnimmt, ISDN war ein Thema, UMTS im Mobilfunkbereich und so weiter, also das, was einen letzten Endes auch im Endgerät interessiert. Heute wollen wir aber aus gegebenen Anlass einen Blick wagen in die Innereien dieses Netzes, also wie funktionieren Telefonnetze intern? Das Einzige, was wir glaube ich damals wirklich angesprochen haben, war, wie es so ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz früher mal war, damals, als man noch rumgebluboxed hat und als die ganzen Telefonvermittlung Stellen so wenig voneinander wussten, dass sie eben relativ leicht zu betrügen und zu übertöpeln waren. Ja, das war dann irgendwann mal zu Ende mit der Einführung von einem Standard, der bekannt ist unter dem Namen SS7 oder auch Signaling System 7. Dazu haben wir uns dann doch etwas bedeckt gehalten und deswegen würde ich an der Stelle eigentlich die Sache wieder aufgreifen. Was verbirgt sich denn hinter diesem Begriff SS7?
Also damals, also über was wir früher gesprochen oder damals gesprochen hatten, das war ja das Signaling System Nummer 5, auch wenn es so noch nicht hieß, sondern CCITT 5 nach der Standardisierungsorganisation. Und das hatte halt diverse Nachteile, wie halt, dass man das relativ leicht überlisten konnte und dass die einzelnen Komponenten des Netzes kaum Informationen austauschen konnten. Und deshalb hat man sich irgendwann im Laufe, im Zuge der Digitalisierung des Telefon-Backbone-Netzes oder der Backbone-Netze, halt ein neues Signalisierungssystem überlegt, dass halt Nachrichten, also die Signalisierung, komplett von der Sprache trennt. Also damals war ja ein Telefonnetz, da wurde halt Sprache übertragen. Heutzutage kann das ja auch anders sein und da passiert noch eine ganze Menge nebenher. Früher wurden halt Anrufe aufgebaut und diese Signalisierungsinformationen, die werden im Signaling System 7, oder wie es abgekürzt heißt, SS7, halt getrennt von der Sprache übertragen.
So wie man das vom ISDN auch erkennt, dass man quasi kein In-Band-Signaling mehr hat, sondern eben Out-of-Band-Signaling. Dann kommt sich das nicht mehr in die Quere. Aber was bedeutet denn das jetzt eigentlich für die physikalische Struktur des Netzes? Also wie sind denn diese Telefonvermittlungsstellen letztlich miteinander verbunden, sodass sie überhaupt miteinander reden können?
Naja, die sind halt, also kann ganz unterschiedlich sein, können S2Ms sein, also was man ja auch von ISDN kennt als 30 Telefoniekanäle.
Das wird auch untereinander verwendet?
Ja, das können die auch untereinander verwenden, genau.
Das ist natürlich keine besonders hohe Kapazität.
Nö, das kann man aber auch beliebig hochskalieren und halt auch runterskalieren, je nachdem, was man da wie anbindet mit was für einer Kapazität.
Also hochskalieren, du meinst jetzt mit mehr S2M oder mit anderen Standards?
Mit anderen Leitungsgrößen, die halt einfach eine höhere Kapazität haben.
Wo dann meistens Glasfaser zum Einsatz kommt heutzutage. Gibt es noch Funk?
Na, Funk gibt es insbesondere halt im Mobilfunkbereich natürlich.
Ich meine jetzt, um Vermittlungsstellen miteinander zu verbinden, also solche Stand-Funkstrecken.
So Richtfunkstrecken.
Richtfunkstrecken, genau.
Gibt es auch, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es zwischen den, also ich meine früher war es natürlich, als es die DDR noch gab, war das halt zwischen Westberlin und dem Rest der Republik so. Wie das jetzt heutzutage ist, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, aber es würde mich wundern, dafür liegt eigentlich genug Glasfaser in der Erde, als dass wir das nicht mehr brauchen.
Sprich heute ist alles eigentlich mit hoher Kapazität ausgestartet und ja, eigentlich genießen wir ja noch gerade so eben eine sehr hohe Dienstgüte im Gesamtangebot, sprich Verbindungen kommen vergleichsweise schnell zustande und man hat auch eine verdammt gute Sprachqualität.
Gerade noch so.
Gerade noch so. Aber was, so wie sieht denn das jetzt aus? Also SS7 wird sowohl innerhalb von Vermittlungsstellen desselben Netzbetreiber gesprochen als auch Netzbetreiber übergreift.
Genau.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so eine Vermittlungsstelle bin und mit einer anderen Verbundungsstelle verbunden bin, dann ist das ja eigentlich auch eine mehr oder weniger permanente Verbindung. Also die wissen ja immer, dass sie da sind oder wählen die sich auch an.
Nee, die wählen sich nicht an. Das ist halt im Prinzip so ein bisschen, wie man es vom Internet her kennt. Da gibt es halt die Vermittlungsstellen und die Datenbanken und was halt alles Teil des Netzes ist. Die haben halt alle eindeutige Adressen, sogenannte Pointcodes. Und die schicken halt Nachrichten zwischen einander hin und her.
Pointcodes.
Genau.
Was sind das so für Adressen?
Das sind so drei Byte-Adressen, die halt eine Entität im SR7-Netzwerk eindeutig weltweit identifizieren.
Drei Byte? Mehr gibt es nicht. Mehr gibt es nicht. Also man kriegt nicht mehr Telefonvermittlung.
Das Byte 255 ist reserviert. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, ob die Reservierung schon in Anspruch genommen wurde, ob das jetzt schon erweitert werden musste, aber da das halt wirklich nur Equipment von Telekommunikationsanbietern ist, sollte das eigentlich erstmal ausreichen.
Okay, gut. Und dann gibt es wahrscheinlich so eine Vergabestelle und wenn man irgendwie eine neue Vermittlungsstelle einrichtet, dann kriegt man eine Nummer zugeteilt.
Genau, bzw. halt so Anbieter wie die Telekom oder so was, wenn die eine neue Vermittlungsstelle einrichten, die haben natürlich ihre zugewiesenen Netzbereiche. Das ist auch wie bei IP. So und da nehmen die halt einfach eine weitere Nummer raus. Und dann gibt es halt auch wie bei IP für kleinere Anbieter, gibt es dann halt die Möglichkeit, dass man halt kein ganzes Netz innerhalb des Landes kriegt, sondern sozusagen da gibt es dann so ein paar reservierte Bereiche, woraus man dann Subnetze kriegt quasi. Genau, Cluster heißen die da.
So, das heißt, die kennen sich alle und sie wissen, womit sie verbunden sind und sie erkennen sich auch an dieser Nummer. Aber diese Nummer an sich erkennt man jetzt noch nicht implizit, wem, welchem Provider das ist.
Doch, doch, doch. Also du hast halt sozusagen an der Nummer erkenntst du, aus welchem Land das kommt und zu welchem Netz es gehört.
Also es ist so quasi wie die alte Aufteilung, dass man eigentlich so feste Bereiche gibt in diesem Adressbereich, was das eine und was das andere kennzeichnet.
Genau, genau.
Und wenn dann mal ein Land wegfällt, dann muss man es wieder erinnern. Und okay, das heißt, so und jetzt plappern die alle miteinander und was könnte jetzt passieren? Es passiert erst mal gar nichts. Sondern eigentlich passiert ja immer erst dann was, wenn irgendein Anrufer kommt.
Genau.
Also ich wähle, was weiß ich, in die Schweiz von meinem Festnetzanschluss aus und sage, ich hätte jetzt gerne mal hier, wenn man es Rütli anrufen.
Genau. So, dann guck halt deine Vermittlungsstelle, schaut sich die Nummer an, die du gewählt hast und guck dann halt, also gibt halt unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten. Im einfachsten Fall guckt sie halt einfach in einem Routing-Table nach, so aha, die Nummer fängt so und so an. Die muss also, muss ich irgendwie in Richtung dieses Point Quotes routen. So und es gibt halt verschiedene Elemente. Es gibt halt Signal Transfer Points. Das sind halt genau die, die Nachrichten, also das sind quasi die Router im SS7-Netzwerk. Die schieben halt Nachrichten hin und her. Das heißt, deine lokale Vermittlungsstelle würde wahrscheinlich die Nachricht, dass du da einen Anruf aufbauen willst, einem Signal Transfer Point weiterreichen, der dann weiß, wo das eigentlich genau hingeht. Weil deine lokale Vermittlungsstelle wahrscheinlich nicht irgendwie weltweit komplette Routing-Tabellen hat.
Das heißt, auch wieder ähnlich wie im Internet, gibt es hier auch eine implizite Hierarchie. Es gibt also Vermittlungsstellen, die mehr Routing-Aufgaben übernehmen und welche, die weniger haben. Das heißt, meine lokale Mini-Vermittlungsstelle, die jetzt meinen Stadtteil abdeckt, die ist so konfiguriert, dass sie eigentlich alles nur an ihrer höher geordneten Vermittlungsstelle weiterreicht und sich eigentlich mit den internationalen Kram nicht kümmert.
Wahrscheinlich. Also muss natürlich nicht so sein, aber das ist angenommenerweise so und das ist halt auch das Sinnvollste.
So, das heißt, ich meine, alles, was ich ja erstmal reingieße, ist ja eigentlich eine Telefonnummer.
Genau.
Und wer dekodiert denn die jetzt, wenn da so 00, die Schweiz 41 und so weiter?
Also 00 dekodiert deine lokale Vermittlungsstelle. So und danach hängt es halt echt davon ab, wie das konfiguriert ist. Also wahrscheinlich ist es halt so, dass die, wenn dann da 41 kommt, dass das schon weitergegeben wird an einen Signal-Transfer-Point, der halt irgendwie weiß, wo das jetzt hinzugehen hat.
Das heißt, dass meine Vermittlungsstelle auch mit so einem direkt verbunden sein muss oder geht das dann auch schon unter Umständen über mehrere Hops?
Das kann unter Umständen über mehrere gehen, ja.
Aber dann muss es ja auch sozusagen nochmal ein Routing innerhalb dieses Netzes geben.
Ja, also es kann halt Intermediate Signal-Transfer-Points geben, zu denen man, also wo halt irgendwie so eine kleine Vermittlungsstelle sagt, irgendwie ich gebe einfach alles dahin, irgendwie alles, was mit 0,0 anfängt, gebe ich einfach dahin und der weiß dann schon. Und es kann aber genauso gut sein, dass irgendwie deine lokale Vermittlungsstelle weiß, aha, irgendwie Sachen, die nach, was weiß ich, jetzt halt in die Schweiz gehen, die gebe ich mal in Richtung der Vermittlungsstelle, die da weiter im Süden steht und Sachen, die nach Finnland gehen, gebe ich mal in Richtung der Vermittlungsstelle, die da weiter im Norden steht. Okay, das ist halt einfach alles eine Entscheidung.
Ja genau, es kann ja sein, dass ich im Grenzgebiet ohnehin schon bin und dann ist das, gibt es da irgendeinen Shortcut.
Genau.
Gut, aber was heißt gebe ich da hin? Also ich meine, in dem Sinne gibt ja meine Telefonvermittlungsstelle nicht wirklich meinen Call ab, sondern sie ist ja quasi verpflichtet, den eigentlichen Verbindungsaufbau durchzufinden, weil mein Telefon tut das ja nicht, sondern das ist ja meine Vermittlungsstelle.
Genau, naja, also sie gibt den Call nicht ab, sie leitet sozusagen deinen Call Setup Request weiter.
Ja, ein Paket, so heißt das.
Genau. Das ist halt irgendwie, also das Protokoll, was da gesprochen wird, ist halt der, also iSub, der ISDN User Part von SS7. Und ein Call Setup wird da initial mit der Initial Address Message, IAM, eingeleitet.
Also und ISDN User Part wird auch dann gesprochen, wenn ich nicht ISDN Telefon habe, sondern das wird dann umgesetzt. So, was schickt die in diesem User Part? Die Initial Address Message. Und die geht dann wohin?
Na die geht dann da hin, also die geht dann sozusagen bis in das Zielnetz, bis zu der Zielvermittlungsstelle.
Und dabei wird es unter Umständen von mehreren weitergeroutet. Das heißt, dieses Paket kommt an, da steht drin, ich will zur Vermittlungsstelle. Das heißt, meine muss schon rausfinden, wohin sie es schicken will.
Genau, richtig.
Und wenn sie das aber nicht weiß, dann?
Na, also sie wird das wissen. Die wird irgendeinen Routing-Table haben, wo zumindest als letzte Instanz drinsteht, und alles andere ruht mal dahin.
So ein Default-Routing. Okay, und dann würde es so ein Default-Routing geben, mit ich hab keine Ahnung, mach du das mal, da gibt es eine Zentrale, die nimmt dann auch dieses Paket und leitet es sozusagen weiter.
Genau, die guckt dann halt nach irgendwie, also plus 4 1, aha, das geht irgendwie, geht da und da hin und bzw. wahrscheinlich gleich irgendwie plus 4 1 und dann noch die nächsten paar Ziffern, okay, das ist dieses und jenes Netz und das schicken wir dann mal gleich zu der Vermittlungsstelle dieses Netzes weiter.
Und was für Daten werden jetzt mit diesem Paket noch mit übertragen? Also ist es jetzt eigentlich nur so die Zielrufnummer?
Ne, also SR7 ist extrem feature-rich und sehr...
Gesprächig.
Sehr gesprächig, genau. Also da wird natürlich irgendwie alles, was man schon vom ISDN kennt, mit übertragen. Also welche Art die Daten haben, die übertragen werden. Also die Bureau Capability und halt ohne Ende Rufnummerninformationen. Also irgendwie natürlich dein Absenderrufnummer, die Zielrufnummer. Ist dieser Anruf umgeleitet? Was für Rufnummern sollen noch irgendwie als zweite Rufnummer übermittelt werden?
Und meine Absenderrufnummer wird auch dann übermittelt. Wenn ich eigentlich gesagt habe, dass sie dem Gegenüber nicht angezeigt werden soll.
Genau, weil das ist genau nur das, nämlich dass sie dem Gegenüber nicht angezeigt wird.
Aber das Netzwerk hat sie. Braucht sie das auch?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also bis zu bestimmten Punkten auf jeden Fall, klar. Weil so kann ja sein, dass irgendwelche Nachrichten zu dir zurückgehutet werden sollen.
Das würde dann auch über diese Telefonnummer gemacht werden?
Genau, weil du hast ja keinen Point-Code im Netz, sondern du hast ja nur eine Telefonnummer im Netz.
Ja, aber ist nicht in diesem Call-Paket sozusagen auch meine eigene Vermittlungsstelle als ursprünglicher Originator, dieser Nachricht, der drin ist?
Natürlich, klar. Aber was ist, wenn jetzt irgendwie, es soll jetzt eine Nachricht zu dir persönlich zurückgeroutet werden? Zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, derjenige, den du anrufen wolltest, ist nicht erreichbar oder da ist besetzt und du aktivierst Rückruf bei besetzt. Dann muss diese Nachricht, dass der Anruf jetzt frei ist, zu dir zurückgeroutet werden.
Das heißt, meine Telefonnummer ist auch innerhalb dieses Telefonnetzes die einzige Adresse, die es gibt. Es gibt jetzt nicht noch irgendeine Vermittlungsstelle, Punkt, mein Teilnehmeranschlussnummer oder sowas, sondern es ist einfach die Telefonnummer. Aber diese Telefonnummern sind auch teilweise auch sehr virtuell. Also ich meine, dass jetzt wirklich so eine Nummer eindeutig so im Ort zugeordnet werden kann, das war doch früher. Heute kann ich doch irgendwie umziehen. Ich habe eine Telefonnummer noch aus so einem Pool vom anderen Provider übernommen, wo ich früher gewohnt habe oder ich habe sogar, was weiß ich, so eine 0700-Nummer oder sowas.
Okay, das sind jetzt gleich ganz viele verschiedene Sachen. Also es ist tatsächlich so, deine normale Festnetznummer, die ist ja immer noch einem Ort zugeordnet, also tatsächlich einer Stadt sozusagen oder einem Dorf, einer Gemeinde wie auch immer und einem Land. So und wenn du jetzt irgendwie nach Hamburg ziehst von Berlin, dann kannst du auch deine Nummer nicht mitnehmen. Also die Berliner Nummer bleibt immer eine Berliner Nummer. So und also das heißt, anhand der Nummer kann auch jemand, kann auch ein Netzwerk, was irgendwie in Peru sitzt, kann sehen, aha dieser Call geht nach Berlin. So was innerhalb des des lokalen Netzes passiert, da gibt es halt inzwischen wegen der Mobile Number Portability, also dass man seine Nummer innerhalb des Netzes beliebig mitnehmen kann, gibt es da halt fette Datenbanken, wo halt drin steht, wo ein Call letztlich hinzugehen hat. Und das funktioniert im Festnet so, dass eine Nummer immer erst mal dahin geroutet wird, wie es in der alten Routing-Tabelle drin steht, wo sie hinzugehen hat, wo sie hin gehört und das Netz sagt dann im Zweifelsfall, oh das ist hier gar nicht mehr, geh mal da und dahin. Im Mobilfunk ist das anders. Und was war noch das 0700-Nummer, hattest du noch angesprochen? Das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Das ist sozusagen einer der Gründe, der damals immer, also das ist das intelligente Netz. Das ist viel, viel Beschworene. Was damals irgendwie sozusagen, womit die SS7-Einführung überhaupt begründet wurde, wurde halt gesagt, ja wir haben dann das intelligente Netz. Die Amis waren da ganz scharf drauf, weil dann konnten sie nämlich 0800-Nummern einführen, die wir inzwischen auch haben. Früher hießen die mal 0130 bei uns. Also Nummern, die kostenlos sind, wenn man sie anruft. Und da gibt es ja noch eine ganze Menge andere. Dieser Service-Nummer hat zum Beispiel 0700-Nummer, 0900-Nummer, 080 irgendwas. Die halt alle gemeinsam haben, dass sie virtuelle Telefonnummern sind. Das heißt, die sind nicht wirklich einem Anschluss zugeordnet. Es gibt jetzt keinen Telefonanschluss, der eine 0800-Nummer hat oder 0900-Nummer oder 0700-Nummer. Sondern das ist halt irgendwo ein Record in einer Datenbank. Diese Datenbanken heißen bei SS7 Service Control Points, SCP. Und wenn man also eine solche Nummer anruft, dann muss erst mal so eine Datenbank befragt werden, wo dieser Chorden jetzt tatsächlich hinzugehen hat.
Und ist das eine Datenbank des jeweiligen Netzbetreibers und jeder hat so seine eigene? Oder ist das so eine deutschlandweite, von der Bundesnetzagentur betriebene oder sonst wie irgendeiner Behörde unterstehende Datenbank?
Genau. Also was jetzt so 0800-Nummern und so was angeht, das ist halt deutschlandweit. Und die werden, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, glaube ich von T-Systems betrieben.
Ah, für alle. Genau. Weil letztlich macht es ja nur Sinn, dass das in einer Datenbank drinsteht.
Genau.
Gut, vielleicht zurück zu dem Verbindungsaufbau. Also im Festnetz, und wir gehen jetzt mal nur vom Festnetz erst mal aus, gibt es also einfach eine Absendenrufnummer, die mag zwar teilweise mobil sein, aber lässt sich zumindest auf eine Stadt und dann innerhalb der Stadt auch auf eine Vermittlungsstelle zurückführen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Das ist jetzt sozusagen auch meine Absendenkennung im Netz und die geht auch mit meinem Anrufwunsch nach draußen. So, jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, dass dieser Telefonanschluss erreichbar ist, sprich, das Telefon klängelt.
Und dann wird es Verbindungen hergestellt. Und dann muss ja sozusagen auch ein wirklicher Leitungskanal hergestellt werden.
Genau.
Und wie geht das jetzt?
Also, die, nachdem die Signaling-Informationen ausgetauscht sind, wird dann halt, also da wird halt gesagt, ich brauche, da steht ja, wie gesagt, die sogenannte Bira-Capability drin und die besagt ja, ich brauche einen Kanal dieser Qualität. Und der wird dann halt, der wird dann halt reserviert, so von Ende zu Ende. Und sobald halt die Connect-Message gekommen ist, können dann darüber halt Daten ausgetauscht werden.
Wird reserviert, also in dem Moment, wo, also erstmal klingelt es ja und dann geht wahrscheinlich erstmal ein Paket wieder zurück, um dem Anrufer zu sagen, jetzt klingelt es.
Genau.
So, kommt denn das Tut, wo kommt denn das Tut-Tut her?
Das kann unterschiedlich sein. Also insbesondere, also im Festnetz ist es eigentlich, also ist mir nichts anderes bekannt, als dass es immer von der Zielvermittlungsstelle kommt, tatsächlich. So, aber im Mobilfunk ist es tatsächlich so, beziehungsweise ich überlege gerade, ich glaube auch bei einigen anderen, so wenn man zum Beispiel Genion, also hier O2-Festnetz-Nummern anruft und solche Geschichten, also die halt auf ein Mobiltelefon geleitet werden und so, auch die haben, glaube ich, inzwischen Signaling, das halt besagt irgendwie, dass halt dem Equipment, was an der Seite des A-Teilnehmers, also des Anrufers sitzt, sagt, generiere mal ein Freizeichen.
Das heißt mein Telefon.
Genau, dein Telefon kriegt halt tatsächlich eine, also in der Nachricht, wo halt drin steht, es klingelt jetzt, da steht dann halt auch drin, irgendwie generiere mal das Freizeichen.
Das heißt, man braucht sich gar nicht mehr wundern, warum alle Klingeltöne auf einmal gleich sind?
Genau, es ist allerdings in der Tat so, dass sozusagen das Equipment auf der Zielseite keine Möglichkeit hat, festzustellen, ob das jetzt auch wirklich so richtig passiert, dass da dieser Ton generiert wird. Deshalb wird auch immer noch ein In-Band-Signaling erzeugt, aber...
Es steht einem frei, das durchzuschalten oder nicht?
Genau, richtig.
Ah, aber das gilt dann auch für ein Ausland. Auch für Auslandscalls.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt, dieses übliche, wenn ich in England anrufe, habe ich ein deutlich anderen Klingelton-Feeling. Das ist nicht mehr garantiert, dass man das bekommt.
Das ist nicht garantiert. Das ist allerdings in den meisten Fällen tatsächlich noch so. Also da habe ich es noch nicht anders erlebt. Ich habe das bisher nur in Deutschland erlebt, dass man halt dann ein vom Telefon generiertes Freizeichen oder Besetzzeichen oder was auch immer bekommt.
Woran hast du das überhaupt gemerkt?
Zuerst habe ich es gehört, weil sich das sehr klar, also sehr rein sozusagen anhörte. Und es hat sich nicht angehört, als käme das von irgendwo anders, sondern das hat sich wirklich angehört, als würde es von meinem Telefon generiert werden.
Du hattest also Grund zur Annahme, dass es von deinem Telefon generiert wird.
Genau, richtig.
Du kannst es nicht mit letzter Sicherheit sagen.
Doch, und dann habe ich in die Signaling-Informationen geguckt, also in den D-Kanal meines ESDN-Anschlusses und habe gesehen, dass es auch wirklich generiert war.
Woran hast du das gesehen?
Na ja, da war halt irgendwie die Signaling-Information, generiere mal ein Freizeichen.
Ach so, okay, wurde sozusagen explizit aufgefordert, das zu tun.
Also es ist, glaube ich, wenn ich...
Dein Mobiltelefon wurde in dem Moment aufgefordert?
Nein, mein...
Dein ESDN-Endgerät? Die können das auch?
Kommt drauf an. Also gibt halt so eine und solche.
Das heißt, wenn sie es nicht können, können sie auch immer noch sagen, nee, mach ich nicht?
Wenn sie es nicht können, dann schalten sie halt einfach den Kanal durch und dann hörst du halt das, was von der anderen Seite gehen wird.
Aber ankommen tut es zu dem Zeitpunkt sozusagen schon. Sie können nur sich entschließen, das einfach sein zu lassen.
Genau.
Weil so ein ausländischer Klingelton kommt mir hier nicht ins Telefon. So, jetzt nimmt der angerufene ab und dann wird die Verbindung hergestellt. Das heißt, die Vermittlungsstelle stellt fest, dass hat er angenommen, also hat sein Telefon abgehoben. Und das heißt, zu dem Zeitpunkt gibt es ja sozusagen diesen Sprachkanal bereits. Also schon mit dem Klingeln ist ja eigentlich der Sprachkanal hergestellt, weil da ist ja ein Klingelton drauf.
Genau. Bloß zu dem Zeitpunkt erst in die eine Richtung.
Ah ja, richtig. Das heißt, in dem Moment sagt er dann der, also meiner Vermittlungsstelle, da von wo der Call ausgeht, dass er doch jetzt bitte auch mal einschalten soll.
Genau.
Also seitdem, dass er angenommen hat und dann macht er es von alleine. Und das war's. Das heißt, eigentlich verhält sich dieses ganze Telefonnetz nicht so sehr viel anders, als man das jetzt so von ISDN auch schon herkennt. Also man redet eigentlich von Vermittlungsstelle zu Vermittlungsstelle nicht sehr viel anders, als man jetzt von Endgerät zu Vermittlungsstelle redet.
Richtig, ja. Könnte man so sagen. Genau, ja. Also eigentlich, es werden Kanäle alloziert, es werden Signaling-Nachrichten ausgetauscht. Ja, eigentlich funktioniert das ungefähr genauso.
Jetzt ist ja die Struktur von den Mobilfunknetzen anders. Also was sprechen die denn? Sprechen die denn auch SS7?
Genau, die sprechen auch SS7, die sprechen auch iSub, wenn es darum geht, also den ESDN Userpart, wenn es darum geht, Anrufe aufzubauen. Bloß haben Mobilfunknetze ja einfach vollkommen neue Anforderungen, die es so in Telefonnetzen vorher noch nie gab. Also man hat halt die Möglichkeit, sich an einem vollständig anderen Ort aufzuhalten und will da immer noch unter seiner Telefonnummer erreichbar sein. Und es gibt zum Beispiel Prepaid-Karten, die halt auch im Ausland funktionieren sollen, wo man nicht über das vorhandene Guthaben kommen soll. Man kann SMSen hin und her schicken. All so eine Geschichten gibt es da.
Gibt es SMS eigentlich mittlerweile rein technisch, auch im Festnetz?
Ja, also ja, es gibt ja, du kannst ja SMS verschicken von deinem Festnetz-Telefon und auch empfangen. So allerdings funktioniert das tatsächlich meistens so, dass eine Modem-Verbindung aufgebaut wird zu deinem Endgerät.
Ohje, Augenroll. Also anstatt dass man sagt, okay wir aktualisieren jetzt mal die Endgeräte.
Naja, der Punkt ist halt, dass ein Großteil, also der Trend geht ja gerade wieder weg von ISDN. Die Anzahl der ISDN-Anschlüsse sinkt ja sozusagen wieder gegenüber den Analog-Anschlüssen. Weil früher brauchten die Leute halt den zweiten Kanal, um da Internet drüber zu machen. Das fällt jetzt halt weg. Und wenn du nur ein Analog-Telefon hast, dann bleibt ja keine viel andere Möglichkeit, als da halt eine Modem-Verbindung zu machen, um eine SMS zu übertragen. Und da das halt eh schon gemacht wird, um Rufenmann zu übertragen mit den Modem-Verbindungen, also natürlich sehr knapp kurzer Form mit geringer Datenübertragungsrate, hat man so was Ähnliches halt auch für SMS gemacht. Und das wird auch an ISDN-Endgeräten so genutzt. Es gibt zwar auch einen Standard, der halt bei ISDN, der sozusagen eine Möglichkeit bietet, direkt quasi als ISDN-Nachrichten SMS zu übertragen, aber der wird quasi nicht benutzt. Naja, dann müsstest du ja unterscheiden, ist das jetzt ein ISDN-Teilnehmer oder ist es keiner? Und die Endgeräte müssten ganz andere sein, wobei du halt heutzutage, ich meine, wenn Telefone verkauft werden, heutzutage sind das fast immer schnulleres Telefone. Und die können dann halt einfach ein anderes, sozusagen entweder analog oder ISDN, können sie halt austauschen. Alles, was dahinter sitzt, kann halt gleich bleiben.
Der Trend geht wieder zurück zum Analogen, beziehungsweise es wird dann auch wieder digital. Da kommen wir auch gleich drauf. Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Mobilfunk. Ich habe ja hier schon mal eine Sendung gemacht, da muss ich jetzt auch noch mal drauf hinweisen, wer das noch nicht kennt und wen das jetzt im Detail noch interessiert. Die Sendung zum GSM-Hack habe ich mal in Wien aufgenommen. Chaosradio Express 56 mit Steve, der dann sich auch konkret zu den Sicherheitsmängeln von GSM-Netzen äußert, aber eben auch noch mal zu der Grundstruktur. Ich kann das jetzt aber schon nochmal kurz wiedergeben, weil das ja in diesen Kontext reinpasst. Also du hast schon gesagt, Mobilfunknetze haben jetzt eine ganz andere Anforderung, weil man eben mobil ist und nicht von so vielen Annahmen ausgehen kann, wie das beim Festnetz eben der Fall ist. Das heißt, diese Mobilfunknetze funktionieren intern, vollständig anders, aber die eigentliche Rufvermittlung zu anderen Anschlüssen ist dasselbe in grün.
Genau. Wobei es da natürlich auch zusätzliche Felder gibt, aber im Prinzip werden da Eishab-Nachrichten ausgetauscht. Und das funktioniert. Also jedes Mobiltelefon ist quasi ein ESDN-Endgerät, um das mal so ganz vereinfacht zu sagen. Aber die haben halt einfach deutlich zusätzliche Funktionalität. Also sowohl die Telefone als auch die Netze, um halt die zusätzliche Funktionalität der Telefone unterstützen zu können. Und die machen auch einiges anders. Zum Beispiel wird nicht mehr zu Point Codes geroutet, sondern im Mobilfunk wird nach Global Titles geroutet. Global Titles sind im Prinzip Telefonnummern. Und das heißt, da hat dann auch die Vermittlungsstelle einfach eine Telefonnummer. Und das hat den Vorteil, dass da sehr viel hierarchischer geroutet werden kann. Und da braucht man dann halt Signal Transfer Points, die halt diese Global Titles in Point Codes, also es ist quasi so ein ganz bisschen, könnte man sagen, ist es so wie DNS im Internet.
Man löst sich sozusagen von diesen Point Codes, von diesen limitierten Adressen aus dem Festnetz.
Genau.
Und ersetzt sie durch Telefonnummern.
Genau. Im Endeffekt haben die natürlich alle immer noch Point Codes. So. Aber man kann halt mittels einer Telefonnummer dahin routen, was halt den Vorteil hat, dass man deutlich feiner aufgelöst routen kann. Und man braucht auch keine endlosen Tabellen mehr, wo halt drin steht irgendwie, das wird dahin geroutet, das wird dahin geroutet. Man muss nur wissen, okay, das geht an das Land. Die Vermittlungsstelle steht in dem Land, das rute ich halt mal in die Richtung und so weiter. Man braucht dann halt nur noch ein paar Signal Transfer Points, die halt Global Title Translation machen können und das in Point Codes übersetzen können.
Die haben immer schöne Namen für alles.
Ja, nicht wahr?
Wie kommen die da drauf?
Gute Frage.
Es scheint so eine ganz andere Kultur zu sein. Das ist irgendwie alles nicht so netzig. Nicht alles so, also nicht so wie man das jetzt so aus der Internetwelt herkennt, oder? Also ich meine Global Title für eine Adresse, da würde doch im Internet kein Mensch draufkommen.
Ja, genau. Zum Beispiel die eindeutigen Seriennummern, die jedes Mobiltelefon weltweit hat, die E-Mail-Nummern, die gibt es ja in einer Version für GSM und für CDMA-Netze. Und die GSM-Telefone oder UMTS-Telefone haben halt alle dezimale E-Mails und die CDMA-Telefone haben welche mit hexadezimalen Digits drin, so dass man die auseinanderhalten kann. Und diese Nummern werden jeweils vergeben vom Global Hexadecimal Administrator oder vom Global Decimal Administrator. Das hätte ich auch gerne auf meiner Visitenkarte stehen.
Ja, das ist super, oder? Oh, Global, super, da sehe ich so richtig so ein Tempel irgendwie so rot leuchtend auf so einem Hügel stehen und so weiter, wo man sich so seine hexadezimalzahlen aushändigen lassen kann. Wo sitzt denn der?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wir wissen es nicht. Ja, aber jetzt vielleicht nochmal so SS7 und die Mobilfunknetze. Also vielleicht nochmal kurz die Struktur, also so ein Mobilfunknetz funktioniert ja im Kern so. Ich laufe halt mit meinem Mobilfunknetz durch die Telefon durch die Gegend. Das heißt, ich bin halt mobil und nicht fest. Das heißt, ich habe auch keine feste Vermittlungsstelle in dem Sinne, sondern ich wechsle am laufenden Meter meine Basisstation, wie das so schön heißt, mit der ich verbunden bin und werde dann von der Basisstation quasi immer wieder an das eigentliche Mobilfunknetz zurückgemeldet, wo ich mich denn jetzt gerade befinde.
Genau.
Wenn ich es richtig erinnere, ist das dieses Home Location Register.
Genau. Home Location Register ist halt eine fette Datenbank, in der halt deine gesamten Subscriber-Informationen drinstehen. Da steht halt drin, wie deine Telefonnummer ist, wie die Nummer deiner SIM-Karte ist, weil die Telefonnummern im GSM oder Mobilfunknetz sind ja auch nur virtuell. Deshalb kannst du ja auch, wenn deine SIM-Karte verloren geht oder so, die schön schnell austauschen. Weil deine SIM-Karte ist eigentlich deine eigentliche Nummer, die IMSI. Und da steht halt drin, was du alles darfst, was du nicht darfst und wo du gerade zu finden bist und so eine Sache.
Wie viel Geld du noch auf dem Konto hast.
Genau. Wenn man Prepaid hat.
Und wie spielt das jetzt zusammen? Ich meine, um es mal perfekt zu nehmen, du hast ja auf dem letzten Kongress einen Vortrag gehalten, der sich mit SS7 auseinandergesetzt hat, aber jetzt nicht so wie wir da jetzt rangehen mit wie funktioniert das, sondern du hast da sowas herausgefunden.
Genau. Also die Frage war ja mal, also in SS7 ist es ja so, zu der Zeit, als das designt wurde, waren die Telefongesellschaften halt alles Staatsmonopole oder halt es gab halt nur eine in einem Land oder zwei oder sowas und dementsprechend wurde da keinerlei Authentifizierung eingebaut untereinander. Das heißt, jeder kann Nachrichten an jeden schicken und vor allen Dingen kann auch jeder reinschreiben irgendwie, hallo ich komme von da und ich bin der und der und es gibt halt keine Möglichkeit, das zu überprüfen.
Das heißt, die Vermittlungsstellen untereinander.
Genau, die Vermittlungsstellen untereinander können sich im Prinzip alle was vormachen, was halt normalerweise nicht so besonders viel ausmacht, da wenn du da reinschreibst, irgendwie die Nachricht kommt gar nicht von mir, sondern die Nachricht kommt von jemand ganz anderem, dann geht halt die Antwort an jemand ganz anderen zurück und der sagt irgendwie, aber es ist doch ein geschlossenes Netz, da kommt man doch nicht so ohne weiteres rein. Naja, das war halt früher so, inzwischen ist es halt nicht mehr so richtig geschlossen, weil ich meine, du kannst jetzt halt losgehen und sagen, ich mache jetzt einen VoIP-Provider auf und da brauchst du halt auch SS7-Access, um da Calls routen zu können und das ist halt alles nicht mehr so, also das ist immer noch mit ein bisschen finanziellem Aufwand und so verbunden, aber das ist jetzt halt nicht mehr so dramatisch, du musst jetzt kein Staatsmonopolist mehr sein, um SS7-Access zu bekommen. So, das lässt sich halt mit relativ geringem Aufwand, kann man da inzwischen Access bekommen.
Aber dann reichen doch diese komischen drei Byte-Point-Codes hinten und vorne nicht aus, wenn jetzt jeder VoIP-Anbieter auch noch Vermittlungsstellen im Netz platziert.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin gerade nicht ganz auf dem Laufenden, ob die da inzwischen schon die Reserve in Anspruch nehmen oder nicht. Aber bisher scheint es zu reichen. Also jedenfalls von der großen Shortage habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Gut, aber das ist natürlich jetzt eine interessante Sache. Also dieses traditionelle Telefonnetz, wo vorher einfach nur die Postgesellschaften aller Welt, so dieser Integre-Club alleine im Sandkasten gespielt hat, wird jetzt quasi überrannt. Von allen möglichen Firmen geht weder Größenordnung und was, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen Voice-over-IP-Services anbieten möchte, also Telefondienste übers Netz, das machen ja viele, anbieten möchte, dann brauche ich eine Verbindung zum Telefonnetz. Und dann bekomme ich die in Form von zum Beispiel von so einem S2M-Anschluss, so einem ISDN-Plexer oder so, was du eingangs meintest. Das heißt, ich habe so meine 30-Kanäle-Leitungskapazität, die ich quasi zur Verfügung stellen kann, unabhängig von der Signalisierung. Und tatsächlich spreche ich über dieses S2M-SS7 anstatt das normale D-Kanal-Protokoll für den End-User-Anschluss. Also ist das dann ein anderes D-Kanal-Protokoll?
Ja, richtig. Also ich meine, es gibt ja so den D-Kanal, den es an sich bei SS7 nicht gibt. Da gibt es halt so die Message Transfer Parts, die sozusagen den Physical Layer, den Data Link Layer und den Network Layer abdecken. Und dazu kommt dann das. Signal Connection Control Part, der ist auch noch Network Layer. So und da drauf sitzt dann halt ISAP, also der ISDN User Part. Und es kommt halt so ein bisschen drauf an, wie groß oder wie professionell du das machen willst, ob du halt da einfach, ob das normaler sozusagen Telefonanschluss ist, also ein End-User-Anschluss, oder ob du halt SS7 machst, aber wenn du halt tatsächlich irgendwie Calls schon in etwas größerem Maßstab irgendwo hinruten möchtest und da also tatsächlich als Telefonanbieter auftreten willst, dann sollte das halt schon SS7 sein.
Ja, davon reden wir jetzt, dass ich selber Telefonanbieter sein will. Das heißt, dann muss ich aber sozusagen, also ich benutze eigentlich normale ISDN-Hardware damit, kann das quasi mit so einem PC machen, aber ich kann nicht das normale ISDN-Protokoll sprechen, so wie man das normalerweise tut.
Genau, du brauchst halt Software, die SS7 spricht. Es gibt halt zum Beispiel inzwischen OpenSS7, so ein Projekt irgendwie, die den Protokoll-Stack, also einige Protokolle davon, halt quelloffen zu implementieren.
Das funktioniert auch schon so weit, dass man damit arbeiten kann, oder ist das erst mal so?
Ich habe es selber noch nicht ausprobiert, keine Ahnung, wie da der Status ist, aber ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessanter Ansatz.
Okay, gehen wir mal einfach davon aus, dass ich jetzt diese Vorgaben habe. Dann gehe ich zu dem großen Registrar und sage, hallo, ich will jetzt an einem Internet teilnehmen, also an dem Telefon-Internet sozusagen teilnehmen und dann kriege ich auch eine offizielle Nummer, sagen wir mal jetzt, ein Point-Code und dann kann ich aber jetzt mit jedem anderen reden und irgendwie so tun, als wäre ich jemand anders.
Ja, im Prinzip kannst du das machen. Du kannst halt bloß nicht, also mit jemandem reden ist ja immer so ein bisschen Kommunikation, das heißt irgendwie so zwei Wege Geschichte und der Punkt ist einfach wie im IP-Netz, du kannst auch deine IP-Adresses bufen, bloß dann kriegst du keine Antworten.
Ja, eben.
So, das ist halt, das ist so der Punkt und ja, deshalb hat sozusagen, hat das nur recht begrenzte Anwendungen mit diesem Ich-bin-jemand-anders-Sagen. Also ein Telefongespräch kannst du so nicht aufbauen. Okay. Aber man kann halt, also insbesondere im Mobilfunknetz hat sich das ja alles ganz schön wegbewegt vom reinen Telefonieren und da gibt es halt diverse Dinge, die man, die man machen kann, die halt nichts mit Telefonen zu tun haben, die halt nicht unbedingt auf einer Zwei-Wege-Kommunikation beruhen. Zum Beispiel irgendwie das Versenden einer SMS ist halt einfach tatsächlich, ich schicke ein Paket, wohin, mit dem Inhalt dieser SMS und dann wird diese SMS ausgeliefert.
Und ich höre auch nicht wieder was von...
Naja, also du kriegst natürlich, kriegst du eigentlich schon zurückgemeldet, so die SMS ist jetzt angekommen oder ist nicht angekommen oder warum sie nicht angekommen ist und so eine Geschichten. Bloß wenn dich das nicht interessiert, kannst du halt einfach eine SMS verschicken und die kommt dann vielleicht an oder nicht, das kannst du dann nicht mehr nachvollziehen. Aber wenn du da halt reinschreibst, ich bin nicht, wenn du nicht dein Netz reinschreibst, sondern halt ein anderes Netz da reinschreibst, von dem das kommt, also einen anderen Pointcode und ein anderes SMSC, von dem das kommt, dann wird diese SMS halt diesem Netz in Rechnung gestellt.
Und in die SMS selber kann ich da auch noch einen anderen Absender reinschreiben wahrscheinlich.
Genau, aber das kann man, also das ist eher relativ einfach möglich.
Das heißt, Authentifizierung, das ist irgendwie, das kommt irgendwie am laufenden Meter. Also das ist ja, also wirklich so der, der mittlerweile schon so der prototypische Designfehler von Netzwerken, ist man in der Authentifizierung, in der Annahme, dass eigentlich hier nur die Guten miteinander reden, nicht? Also gerade bei den letzten CRE-Sendungen durchblätter, wie bei E-Mail ist das irgendwie ein großes Thema mit Spam, bei dem Hack vom Deck-System ist das jetzt auch wieder so eins der Hauptursachen für den ganzen, für das ganze Drama gewesen. Und wie wirkt sich das jetzt aus für diese Sache, die du rausgefunden hast, über die du auf dem Kongress berichtet hast?
Naja, also es gibt halt, also was ich eigentlich festgestellt hatte, es gibt halt ein, also um eine SMS zu stellen zu können, muss man erstmal wissen, wo die überhaupt hingehen soll. Und das mit den SMS'n funktioniert ja so, die werden immer direkt an die Zielvermittlungsstelle zugestellt, wo sich jemand gerade aufhält. So, das heißt, wenn du jetzt in Hongkong weilst, gerade, und ich schicke dir eine SMS an deine deutsche Nummer, dann funktioniert das folgendermaßen, dass mein, also das SMSC, also die Kurzmitteilungszentrale meines Netzes, oder fangen wir mal so an, also ich, mein Telefon schickt, schickt die SMS an die Kurzmitteilungszentrale meines Netzes. So, und die Kurzmitteilungszentrale, die guckt sich halt die Nummer an, wo das hingehen soll.
Das sogenannte SMSC.
Genau, Short Message Service Center, guckt sich die Nummer an, wo das hingehen soll, und fragt auf Basis dieser Nummer, findet die das HLR, also dein Home Location Register, dein Datenbank, die alles über dich weiß, raus und fragt dieses HLR, sag mir doch mal, wo der Tim gerade ist. Und das HLR fragt halt, weiß halt sozusagen, dass du dich gerade in Hongkong aufhältst und fragt das Netz da vor Ort, sag mir doch mal bitte, im Bereich, welche Vermittlungstelle Tim gerade ist, der da bei dir im Netz ist.
Also genau genommen weiß es nicht, dass ich da bin, sondern es weiß nur, dass ich da vor kurzem noch war, weil ich mich da mal eingebucht habe. Und dann wird sozusagen, in dem Moment, wo ich mich da irgendwo mal einbuche, was weiß ich, da bin ich hier bei Hongkong Telekom, keine Ahnung, wie heißen da die Provider, drei oder so. Mach ich einen Einbuchsvorgang, der wendet sich an meinen eigentlichen Provider und sagt dann quasi dem Home Location Register, der ist jetzt in Hongkong.
Genau.
Dann steht das jetzt erst mal so lange drin, bis ich mich wieder irgendwo anders einbuche.
Ja, oder nach einem gewissen Timeout.
Wie ist so dieser Timeout?
Ganz unterschiedlich, also wirklich komplett unterschiedlich.
So Minuten, Stunde, Tage, Wochen?
Also ich hab's erlebt von Stunden bis zu Monaten.
Monaten? Was heißt, ich kann nach Hongkong fahren, mein Telefon einmal einschalten und wieder ausschalten und dann fahre ich nach Finnland und dann bin ich ein paar Monate später, meine SMS immer noch nach Hongkong zugestellt, wenn ich es nicht wieder eingeschaltet habe.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Oha.
Genau. Und ja, genau, also dann sagt das, das HLR sagt dann halt der Kurzemitteilungszentrale meines Netzes.
Last Scene in Hongkong.
Genau. Und das ist die Nummer der Vermittlungsstelle, die ich für den zuständig war. So, und dann schickt meine Kurzemitteilungszentrale, schickt dann die SMS direkt an die Vermittlungsstelle in Hongkong.
Aber was heißt Vermittlungsstelle? Ist das dann die Basis-Station?
Nee, das ist tatsächlich also eine Vermittlungsstelle, also ein Mobile Switching Center. Das ist immer angeschlossen an mehrere Base-Station-Controllers, oder besser gesagt die Base-Station-Controllers sind an die Vermittlungsstelle angeschlossen. Und jeder Base-Station-Controller ist sozusagen für mehrere Base-Transceiver-Stations, also das sind sozusagen die Funktürme zuständig. So, weil diese eigentlichen Basis-Stationen, also die Antennen, die sind halt dumm. Die machen wirklich nur, das sind halt wirklich quasi nur Antennen, während halt die Base-Station-Controllers sozusagen das Gehirn dahinter sind.
Aber es gibt sozusagen ein Gehirn für mehrere Antennen. Und dann gibt es wiederum nochmal die mobile Zwitschern-Station, die ganzen Base-Stations zusammenfassen. Genau. Wobei ein Netzwerk sich dann aber unter Umständen auch aus mehreren MSCs, also aus mehreren Zwitschern-Zentralen zusammenfasst.
Genau. Also so wie das im Festnetz auch ist irgendwie, das hat halt nur eine begrenzte Kapazität und...
Kann es aber auch sein, dass ich ja quasi, obwohl ich da jetzt gerade noch gesehen wurde, mittlerweile an einer Basis-Station eingebucht bin, die nicht mehr an dieser MSC angeschlossen ist.
Genau. Da gibt es halt, genau und wegen genauer solcher Sachen ist das halt echt kompliziert geworden im SS7 alles. Also dieser Mobile Application Part, der genau so eine Fälle alle spezifiziert, genau was ist passiert, wenn der, was muss jetzt passieren, wenn derjenige jetzt nicht mehr da ist, wo er eben noch war und so eine Geschichte. Deshalb ist dieser ganze Mobile Application Part halt unglaublich umfangreich geworden. Also, ja, es ist wirklich, wirklich Wahnsinn, wenn man sich da die Standards anguckt, was das alles inzwischen für eine Anzahl an Standards ist und wie umfangreich die alle geworden sind. Und, weil...
Nur für den Mobile Fall, der im Festnetz nach wie vor unkompliziert ist.
Relativ unkompliziert. Also ich meine, da gibt es inzwischen halt auch Mobile Number Portability und so. Aber im Gegensatz zum Mobilfunk ist es halt wirklich um Größenordnungen einfacher. Genau. So, und dann wird halt die SMS hingeschickt zu der Vermittlungsstelle, die halt angesagt wurde, wo du dich gerade aufhältst.
Und in dem Moment, wo ich noch eingebucht bin, würde es sich mir dann auch unter Umständen sofort zustellen.
Genau, richtig. Genau. So, und was mir dann halt mal aufgefallen ist, dass ja, dass eigentlich ganz interessant ist, weil das in der Tat ein Fall ist, wo du eine Information bekommst, wo sozusagen jedes, wo es quasi egal ist, wo du dich in der Welt gerade aufhältst, ich bekomme halt eine Information darüber, wo du ungefähr bist, wenn ich sage, ich will dir eine SMS schicken. So, wenn ich also ans SS7-Netzwerk angeschlossen bin und Roaming Agreements habe mit den Netzen, wo du dich aufhältst, dann kann ich das Netz einfach fragen und natürlich mit deinem Heimatnetz, dann kann ich das Netz einfach fragen, wo du dich gerade aufhältst und unter dem Vorwand dir eine SMS schicken zu wollen.
Wieso kann ich dir denn das fragen? Ich dachte, ich schicke die SMS einfach an das SMSC und das SMSC wird dann selber aktiv.
Nee, klar. Also jetzt nicht du als End-User, sondern als SS7-Teilnehmer quasi, also als jemand, der SS7 Zugang hat.
Ja, klar. Also sozusagen, ich im Auftrag eines Kunden und ich bin seine Vermittlungsstelle, will dir jetzt eine SMS zustellen, aber dann muss ich doch gar nicht fragen, dann schicke ich das auch nur ans SMSC.
Du musst nicht, aber du kannst halt.
Das ist einfach ein Protokoll so drin.
Genau. Aber warum? Naja, der Request ist halt nötig, um rauszufinden, wo jemand ist, um eine SMS dahin zuzustellen.
Aber ich dachte, du schickst es, ach so, wenn man selber ein SMSC ist sozusagen.
Naja, es spielt keine Rolle, was du bist. Es ist nicht so, du musst ja nicht, es gibt ja keine Authentifizierung oder sowas, du musst ja nicht beweisen, dass du ein SMSC bist.
Du bist einfach nur ein Netzwerk und als solches darfst du einfach erstmal alles und wenn man unter anderem auch ein SMSC ist, dann muss man eben auch so eine Information hinterfragen können, weil sonst kann man die SMS nicht zustellen.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Ah, verstehe. Man tut einfach so, als wäre man ein SMSC.
Genau, es gibt da halt diese Requests, die man halt verschicken kann und die sind halt immer gedacht für bestimmte Elemente in der Infrastruktur, also für SMSCs, HLRs, VLRs, MSCs, irgendwie dieser Request wird nur vom HLR ans MSC geschickt und so weiter und dafür ist es halt gedacht, aber...
Es ist nicht so, dass man sich wirklich identifizieren und autentifizieren muss mit ich bin ein HLR, ich bin ein VLR, ich bin ein was auch immer, sondern alle können alles machen und jeder macht natürlich nur das, was er soll, weil alles hat ja seine Ordnung und wir machen keine Fehler.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Aha, so. Aber das heißt, wie viele Leute, wie viele VoIP-Anbieter, ich meine, wie viele Leute tummeln sich denn da jetzt schon so?
Na, das sind viele. Allerdings muss man natürlich sagen, dass die Mobilfunkanbieter schon recht, also Mobilfunkanbieter ist ja nochmal eine etwas andere Klasse. Ob du jetzt irgendwie so ein VoIP-Anbieter bist oder Mobilfunkanbieter, das ist halt schon was anderes. Insbesondere halt, wenn du einfach nur Mobilfunkanbieter bist, ist das halt relativ witzlos. Die Roaming-Agreements machen es halt. So, wenn du jetzt, wenn ich Mobilfunknetz aufbaue und irgendwo mein SS7-Peering habe, aber keine Roaming-Agreements, dann kann ich Nachrichten verschicken, wie ich will, mir antwortet kein Mensch. Genau. Das heißt, man braucht jetzt jemanden, der halt Roaming-Agreements hat, um so ein Request absetzen zu können.
Man braucht auch so ein Roaming-Agreement, um eine SMS zuzuschicken.
Das ist genau der Punkt. Bei der SMS brauchst du das halt nicht. Weil dir ist ja egal, ob dir jemand antwortet oder nicht. Verstehe. Da musst du halt nur vorgeben, dass diese SMS aus einem Netz kommt, mit dem ein Roaming-Agreement besteht. Und dann kannst du die SMS da halt hinschicken. Ob die SMS jetzt wirklich aus dem Netz kommt, kann halt nicht mehr überprüft werden. Weil es ja tatsächlich so ist, dass der Vorgang zu fragen, sag mir doch mal, wo jemand ist, ich würde gerne eine SMS zustellen. Und das tatsächliche Versenden der SMS sind halt komplett unabhängig voneinander. Also logisch gesehen.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man am SS7-Netz teilnimmt, kann man für jede Mobilfunknummer fragen, wo ist denn der zuletzt eingebucht gesehen worden?
Das kannst du nur, wenn du halt Roaming-Agreements hast mit dem Netz desjenigen, für den du das fragen willst.
Und was kann ich auch ohne Roaming-Agreement machen? Ein SMS verschicken, ja.
Dafür musst du halt wissen, wo sie hingehen soll.
Dann ist es doch das, was ich meine mit dem Fragen, wo ist er.
Nein, also wie gesagt, das sind zwei logisch getrennte Vorgänge. Einerseits gibt es halt das Fragen, wo ist derjenige. Dafür brauchst du Roaming-Agreements, weil du kriegst sonst einfach keine Antwort. Das eigentliche Verschicken der SMS, das kannst du halt immer machen, wenn du irgendwie ein SS7-Peering hast. Du musst halt nur wissen, wo sie hingehen soll, zu welcher Vermittlungsstelle sie gehen soll.
Das heißt, ohne Roaming-Agreement kann man jetzt auch eine Position nicht hinterfragen?
Genau, richtig. So, und was es halt gibt, ist es gibt halt Services, die bieten dir halt genau diesen Service an. Die haben halt Roaming-Agreements, also die hängen an Netzen dran, die Roaming-Agreements haben, die bieten dir halt genau den Service an. Hier kannst du herausfinden, an welcher Vermittlungsstelle ein Teilnehmer gerade ist, wo der sich gerade aufhält. So, und da kriegst du halt nur die Vermittlungsstellen-Information zurück, also den Global-Title der Vermittlungsstelle. So, und die im Sie dasjenigen, die braucht man auch, um die SMS zu verschicken.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich es erst. Das heißt, ich habe zwar keinen Roaming-Vertrag mit allen, aber es gibt Dienstleister, die haben diese Roaming-Verträge. Die kann ich für mich sozusagen diese Anfrage machen lassen.
Genau.
Und dann bekomme ich die vollständige Information zurück. Aber mit diesen Dienstleistern brauche ich da noch einen Vertrag oder was?
Ganz unterschiedlich.
Was sind denn das für Dienstleister? Ich meine, was machen die denn?
Na, größtenteils machen die halt selber, bieten die halt SMS-Versand an und so und bieten halt sowas auch noch an. Okay. So, und dann weißt du halt, wo die SMS hingehen soll, und dann kannst du halt SMSen losschicken. So, und da kannst du halt reinschreiben. Diese SMS kommt übrigens aus diesem ganz anderen Netz, von diesem ganz anderen SMSC, von dieser und jener Telefonnummer. Und das Zielnetz hat keine Möglichkeit, das zu überprüfen und stellt diese SMS dem Netz, was du da reingeschrieben hast, in Rechnung.
Diese Ortsinformationen, die man jetzt sozusagen von dem Versenden bekommt, wie genau ist die?
Das kommt ganz drauf an. Also zum Beispiel so in einer Stadt wie Berlin jetzt hat halt jedes Netz mehrere Vermittlungsstellen. Das heißt, du kannst also zumindest schon mal sagen, anhand der Vermittlungsstellennummer kannst du theoretisch zumindest mal sagen, derjenige ist in Berlin. Auf dem Land wird das natürlich deutlich ungenauer, weil wo niemand ist, brauchst du auch nicht viele Vermittlungsstellen. Da reichten halt eine für was auch immer, wie viele Leute. Zum Beispiel viele Netzbetreiber haben zum Beispiel ein oder zwei Vermittlungsstellen für Berlin und dann noch mal eine für Brandenburg oder so. Aber du kannst auf jeden Fall immer das Land sehen. Und wenn du halt Informationen hast, also wenn du diese Informationen weiter parsen kannst, kannst du halt meistens auch noch sehen, in welcher Region des Landes sich derjenige auffällt. Oder bei großen Städten halt, in welcher großen Stadt.
Das heißt, man ist im Prinzip bediebig hinterfragbar mit relativ wenig Aufwand. Also wo man ist zumindest oder wo man zuletzt eingebucht war, nachdem der Timeout so lange der Timeout noch nicht abgelaufen ist.
Das wird jetzt auch noch genauer, weil es gibt zum Beispiel neue Requests, also dieser Mobile Application Part, der wird ja auch immer weiter erweitert, für neue Features, die gebraucht werden. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel einen neuen Request, oder relativ neu, nicht mehr so neu inzwischen. Anytime Interrogation heißt der, da erhältst du tatsächlich zurück die Sale ID, also sozusagen die globale ID der Basisstation, in die jemand gerade eingebucht ist. Das heißt, das ist dann meistens so ein Umkreis von ein paar hundert Metern.
Hundert Kilometer auf dem Land.
Genau. Und die Information ist dann tatsächlich auch aktuell, weil bei Anytime Interrogation wird die Information gerade immer noch mal aktuell abgefragt.
Es gab doch auch mal so eine Geschichte mit so einer Silent-SMS zur Ortsbestimmung. Hat das was damit zu tun?
Ja, also was halt gemacht wurde, war eine SMS an, also es haben halt so Strafverfolgungsbehörden, die Bedarfsträger und die gerne gemacht, die haben eine SMS, eine stille SMS an Telefon geschickt, also eine SMS, die dort nicht angezeigt wird, damit das Mobilfunknetz die aktuelle Position desjenigen dann wirklich wusste und dann haben sie beim Netzbetreiber gesagt, so jetzt sag mir mal bitte in welcher Zelle der eingebucht ist.
Aber wieso wird denn die SMS nicht angezeigt?
Es gibt einfach, also Typ 0-SMSen werden nicht angezeigt, das ist im Standard so festgelegt.
Typ 0? Was heißt das? Typ 0?
Das ist einfach wieder nur so eine Bezeichnung.
Das ist einfach so ein Typ 0. Eine SMS, die keine ist. Ah, super.
Also ist halt schon eine SMS sozusagen mit dem ganzen Protokoll. Fladrardatsch, der dahinter ist, mit irgendwie die SMS wird zugestellt und wird acknowledge, dass die SMS angekommen ist. Und dem SMSC wird gesagt, die SMS ist angekommen. Und sozusagen alles, das Ganze dahinter, findet alles statt. Bloß vorne kommt nichts raus.
Und wie kriegt man dann die Positionen darüber raus?
Darüber gar nicht. Aber dann hast du, dann kannst du sicher sein, dass das Mobilfunknetz jetzt tatsächlich weiß, wo du dich gerade aufhältst.
Und dann muss man nur noch einschreiten und nachzufragen.
Dann rufst du beim Netzbetreiber an und sagst, sag mir doch mal bitte irgendwie...
Was da in der Datenbank steht. Genau. Ah ja, okay, verstehe. Da braucht man dann sozusagen noch einen etwas höher priorisierten Zugang zur Datenbank, als man jetzt normalerweise über SMS, über SS7...
Genau. Aber den brauchst du halt nicht mehr, wenn du Anytime Interrogation Requests absetzen kannst. So, weil die schmeißen dir einfach die Cell-ID von demjenigen raus.
Das ist sozusagen das Strafverfolgungs-Feature oder was?
Nee, das hat nichts mit Strafverfolgung zu tun. Also ich meine, zweifellos, wenn die das dann auch haben wollen. Aber eigentlich ist das für, ist das für im Zuge dieser ganzen Location-Based Services und also Camel ist da das Stichwort, was eine weitere Phase dieses ganzen Mobile Application Parts ist, was halt...
Camel.
Genau, Camel. Das ist wieder so eine Abkürzung, die ich jetzt gerade nicht zusammenkriege, die halt dafür zuständig ist... Du hast hier Störungen. Du bist im GSM eingebucht.
Ja, ich bin im GSM eingebucht. Weiß gar nicht warum.
Weil UMTS hört man nämlich nicht.
Ja, ich weiß. Sollte ich ehrlich nicht sagen.
Ich bin im UMTS eingebucht. Dieses Kämmerl hat zum Ziel, ein virtuelles Environment einzurichten, dass Leute, egal wo sie sind, ihr Telefon wirklich so benutzen können, als wären sie zu Hause. Inklusive von Kurzwahlen, die sie benutzen können, und keine internationalen Nummern, die sie anwählen müssen. Und man selber kann immer abfragen, wie viel Guthaben man noch auf seiner Prepaid-Karte hat und so eine Geschichte. Und da kommen halt auch natürlich Location-Based Services mit rein. Und für die ist halt dieser Anytime Interrogation Request gedacht, unter anderem. Also der hat halt ganz viele Anwendungen. Der sagt dir zum Beispiel auch, kann dir auch sagen, welche E-Mail das Telefon von demjenigen hat und so eine Geschichte. Und der ist natürlich größtenteils eigentlich für den Netzbetreiber selber gedacht, so. Also damit der irgendwie dir diese Features zur Verfügung stellen kann. Weil zum Beispiel sowas wie eine Homezone, die hast du halt nur in deinem Heimatnetz, der braucht nicht zu wissen, in welcher Zelle du dich aufhältst, wenn du in einem anderen Netz bist. Aber wie das halt so ist, da wird halt bei den Netzbetreibern Equipment hingestellt und die Netzbetreiber selber betreiben ja irgendwie meistens gar nicht mehr viel Netz, sondern da hast du halt die Equipment-Manufacturer, die da halt ein- und ausgehen und die da ihre Leute gleich mitliefern und das wird da halt hingestellt und betrieben und wenn es läuft, ist halt gut. Und dann guckt dann auch nicht jemand mehr viel drauf und es gibt halt also jetzt schon weiß ich von einigen Netzbetreibern, die einfach diese Anytime Interrogation Requests auch von außen beantworten.
Also von anderen SS7-Teilnehmern? Genau. Das heißt auch hier kann wieder der kleine Voice-over-IP-Provider...
Nee, nee, nee, der nicht. Du brauchst ja ein Roaming-Agreement.
Aber wie schwierig ist denn das eigentlich, so ein Roaming-Agreement zu bekommen?
Das kommt immer drauf an. Also ein Roaming-Agreement mit, sozusagen, einem deutschen Mobilfunknetz zu bekommen, sowas wie T-Mobile oder so, ist sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig.
Okay.
Also da gibt es dann allerdings auch so Roaming-Aggregatoren, die halt Roaming-Agreements sammeln und die weiterreichen quasi. Natürlich nur unter strengen Auflagen und so, aber ja, sowas gibt es auch.
Also tendenziell ist festzustellen, SS7 wird nach wie vor gepflegt und erweitert. Es gibt eine ganze Menge neuer Features, die in Mobilfunknetzen insbesondere, teilweise auch in Festnetzen und vor allem im Zusammenspiel von Festnetzen und Mobilfunknetzen gebraucht werden. Vor allem, wenn wir ja mal nichts Falsches unterstellen, vor allem geht es sozusagen darum, neue End-User-Features zu implementieren. Und um die eben zu machen, braucht man eben auch die entsprechende Protokoll-Infrastruktur. Öffnet natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Tür zu potenziellen Fuck-Ups. Ich meine, wenn da jetzt so viel account-spezifische Sachen durchgehen, wie Prepaid-Informationen und so weiter. Und ich meine, auch so Privacy, ich meine, auch so dieses Wer ist wo, so das eine. Dann aber auch so dieses Geräte. Wenn jedes Gerät wirklich jederzeit trackbar ist, dann kann man es auch noch irgendwie beim Weiterreichen nachvollziehen, wie auch immer. Darauf halte ich jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr, mich konzentrieren. Tatsache ist, SS7 ist eigentlich noch voll in Entwicklung, kann man das so sagen.
Ja, wird, also, Teile davon, bestimmte Parts davon werden immer noch deutlich erweitert, also hauptsächlich der Mobile Application Part.
Und es ist so das, was 99,9 Prozent aller Telefonnetze heutzutage sprechen.
Genau.
Oder gibt es noch irgendwas anderes, was in Betrieb ist?
Naja, also es gibt wohl in einigen afrikanischen Ländern gibt es halt noch ältere Netze, die halt noch C5 oder sogar C4 oder so was sprechen. So irgendwo ist dieses ganze alte Equipment hier mal hinverkauft worden.
Verstehe.
So und dann kommt natürlich auch langsam so die nächste Generation an Netzen.
Und jetzt sind wir sozusagen bei der 110 angekommen, der Nummer dieser Sendung, der Notruf. Wir haben schon ein bisschen mit den Augen gerollt. Ja, was verbirgt sich denn hinter diesem Begriff? NGN, das ist glaube ich das Buzzword und es gibt da auch eine Ankündigung der Telekom.
Genau, Next Generation Networks hört sich erstmal ganz toll an. Ja, super, weil in der nächsten Generation wird ja immer alles besser.
Jetzt endlich Zukunft.
Genau, und mit mehr und davon ganz viel. Ja und zwar geht es darum, dass jetzt natürlich alle IP machen wollen, so, weil das macht man jetzt heutzutage so.
Macht man das? Also ich meine, wer macht denn das? Macht das schon jemand?
Ja, also es gibt in der Tat einige Provider in Deutschland, die halt schon NGN-Netzwerke betreiben, zum Beispiel Kabel Deutschland. Die haben halt exklusiv, also bei deren Telefonenetz geht halt über das Fernsehkabel zum Enduser und da wird halt dann IP darüber gesprochen.
Weil die sozusagen auch eh schon keine klassische Telefontechnik einsetzen, brauchen die eh neue Geräte, müssen aber natürlich kompatibel sein zu den bestehenden Telefonnetzen.
Genau, die sprechen nach draußen, also zu den anderen Netzen sprechen sie SS7 und der Kunde hat zu Hause weiterhin sein Analogtelefon stehen, aber zwischendrin ist halt alles IP, also netzintern ist alles IP und bis zum Kunden, bis zu Hause zum Kunden, bis zu dessen Modem ist auch alles IP.
Das heißt, die Kunden werden jetzt eigentlich mit Internet versorgt, man legt dort große Bandbreiten hin. Ich weiß nicht, bei Kabel Deutschland ist es glaube ich gar nicht so wenig. Und da hat man sich gesagt, jetzt auch noch irgendwie für diese eine Telefonleitung, die im Prinzip in Internetdimensionen ja minimal Bandbreite ist, da jetzt noch eine eigene Art dafür zu verbuddeln, ist eigentlich Quark.
Genau, weil sie haben da schon dickes Kupfer liegen und da jetzt wieder zwei Draht zu verbuddeln, das wäre ein Milliardenaufwand gewesen, der nicht nötig ist.
Genau. Und deswegen macht man einfach auf der End-User-Seite eine kleine Box, die so tut, als wäre sie ein analoger Telefonanschuss. Sich auch natürlich wie einer verhält, deswegen man kann ja sein Telefon anschließen, aber dahinter ist alles IP. Na gut, das ist ja alles schön und gut, aber das ist ja noch lange kein Grund, dass man leicht Telefonnetze auf IP umstellt, oder?
Ja, offensichtlich schon, weil das wird gemacht. Also die Deutsche Telekom will glaube ich bis 2013 oder so was in dem Dreh komplett auf IP umgestellt haben. Intern? Genau.
Innerhalb Ihres eigenen Netzes. Das heißt, anstatt SS7 zu sprechen, innerhalb des Netzes wollen Sie IP sprechen?
Also es gibt verschiedene Stufen. Es gibt verschiedene Stufen. Also einerseits gibt es den langfristigen Plan, SS7 durch SIP zu ersetzen.
Also das Session Initiation Protokoll, was so ein normaler Voice-over-IP-Client spricht.
Genau. Richtig. Und kann sich jetzt jeder selber überlegen, wie geeignet er das dafür hält oder nicht. Es gibt aber natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, SS7 über IP zu machen. Das ist dann das SIG-Tran-Protokoll. Also so passiert das heutzutage bei den meisten VoIP-Provider oder so. Die haben dann IP-Leitungen und darüber sprechen sie halt SS7. Aber langfristig ist halt auch der Plan, SS7 zu ersetzen. Beim Endkunden gibt es halt nicht nur die Kabelprovider, zum Beispiel Alice. Fast alle alternativen, also nicht deutsche Telekom-Anbieter in Deutschland verkaufen schon NGN-Anschlüsse neben ihren normalen analogen Anschlüssen und sagen das meistens auch gar nicht dazu. Das heißt, wenn man sich jetzt bei Alice Telefonen kriegt, kann das halt auch gut sein, dass man halt einen NGN-Anschluss kriegt, was einfach heißt, man telefoniert über die DSL-Leitung, die man bei Alice mitbekommt.
Über IP.
Genau.
Und das heißt auch, dass man auch diesen Spagat mit, ich hol mir jetzt, wenn ich jetzt selber ein Telefonanbieter sein will und ich muss SS7 sprechen, muss ich das nicht mehr über eine S2M-Leitung machen mit dem ganzen Protokollaufwand, den wir schon hatten, sondern ich spreche dieses SS7-Protokoll selber wiederum über IP.
Genau, das geht auch.
Tunneln sozusagen. Das heißt, man macht dann irgendwo eine Verbindung auf, eine normale TCP-Verbindung und dann wird darüber einfach SS7 gesprochen?
Genau.
Ist das auch schon Gang und Gebe oder ist das die Coming-Up?
Nee, nee, das ist großflächig im Einsatz. Also insbesondere so für Signaling-Links, wo dann halt nur zum Beispiel SMSen oder so was drüber gehen.
Ja, das braucht man ja auch sonst viel, das stimmt.
Genau. Also im Prinzip ist das so, verkehrt erstmal gar nicht. Das Problem ist dann natürlich, dass halt so der IP-Link, den man zu Hause hat, also in den meisten Fällen wird es wohl einfach eine DSL-Leitung sein, die halt über zwei Draht-Kupfer bei einem ankommt, dass das halt meistens nicht so an die Qualität ranreicht, die man so von seiner Telefonleitung gewohnt ist. Und das Problem ist, dass in Deutschland sind die Leute halt extrem verwöhnt von der Qualität des Telefonnetzes. Da macht sich im Prinzip niemand Gedanken drüber, weil das Telefon hat immer funktioniert, wenn man den Hörer abgenommen hat, dann hat man die Nummer gewählt, das hat immer geklappt und eigentlich alles super.
Und klingt gut.
Klang immer super, deshalb hat sich da nie jemand wirklich Gedanken drüber gemacht. Und wenn man halt Telefonanschluss sich kriegt oder bestellt, wird halt in den meisten Fällen einfach auf den Preis geachtet. Weil Telefon ist Telefon, also nehme ich halt das, was am wenigsten kostet. Und inzwischen merken halt die ersten Leute, dass das halt längst nicht mehr so ist, sondern also in den letzten Jahren hat die Qualität der Sprachverbindungen halt in vielen Fällen wirklich massiv abgenommen. Und wenn deine Telefonleitung dann über das DSL zu dir nach Hause kommt, dann ist die halt nur noch so gut wie das DSL maximal. Das heißt, wenn du deinen Router ausschaltest, wenn du einen Stromausfall hast, kannst du nicht mehr telefonieren. So, wenn, was in vielen Fällen auch der Fall ist, kein Quality of Service eingesetzt wird, also nicht ein Sprachkanal auf dem DSL tatsächlich reserviert wird, dann ist es auch so, wenn du jetzt...
Dann BitTorrent startest.
Genau, BitTorrent anmachst. Dann kann es halt auch passieren, dass plötzlich das beim Telefonieren ruckelt.
Was man ja nur wirklich überhaupt nicht gewohnt ist.
Genau. Und ja, und da können halt noch so diverse lustige Sachen auftreten. Es ist halt so ein bisschen Betatest beim Endkunden. So wer weiß, ob das ganze Equipment dann auch wirklich alles so tut, wie man das haben möchte und ob sich das genauso verhält. Und was ist, wenn jetzt mal kurz weg war oder in den meisten Fällen ist ja auch so, dass alle 24 Stunden eine Zwangstrennung stattfindet. Dann ist halt auch im Zweifelsfall ein Telefongespräch weg. So und all so lustige Sachen. Und deshalb haben halt viele Leute, die sich irgendwo einen Telefonanschluss bestellt haben und einen NTN-Anschluss gekriegt haben, haben dann halt irgendwie nach einer Weile gesagt, oh Gott, was ist das denn hier? Ich will ganz schnell wieder weg. Und das hat der Telekom letztlich doch auch wieder eine Menge Kunden in die Arme getrieben. Und es gibt auch einige, zum Beispiel Versatel, wirbt jetzt explizit damit, dass sie halt echte ISDN-Anschlüsse verlegen und nix NGN-mäßiges.
Also man kann davon ausgehen, dass die erste Welle beim End-User nicht so gut angekommen ist.
Überhaupt nicht, genau.
Aber es geht ja bei der Ankündigung der Telekom jetzt gar nicht so sehr um die Endkundenanschlüsse.
Genau.
Ich meine, die Telekom hat ja nun wirklich noch ein riesiges ISDN-Potenzial.
Die Telekom möchte irgendwie alle ihre jetzigen Vermittlungsstellen gerne ersetzen. Will das halt alles auf komplett IP umstellen. Und irgendwann, wann das genau der Fall sein wird, weiß man noch nicht. Aber es wird halt im kommenden Jahrzehnt auf jeden Fall sein, werden dann alle Kunden, die noch keinen NGN-Anschluss zu Hause haben, zwangsmirigiert.
Aber ich meine, was heißt das? Dann kommt dann wirklich, wenn ich jetzt einen normalen ESD-Endanschluss habe, kommt dann jemand bei mir zu Hause, klopft an die Türen und sagt, guten Tag, wir sind die nächste Generation und wir schrauben Ihnen jetzt halt so eine Büchse an die Wand.
Na, wahrscheinlich klingelt da der Mann von DHL, oder was heißt ich, und bringt dir halt ein Paket und das stöpselst du halt zwischen die anderen Kästchen. Dazwischen sozusagen. Die Generation hast und in der Theorie funktioniert dann alles wieder so wie vorher. Ich meine, ist jetzt natürlich auch noch ein bisschen Zeit hin und vielleicht kriegen sie das ja auch hin, dass es tatsächlich so ist. So wird man halt sehen.
Hat denn das noch andere Auswirkungen? Ich meine, im Prinzip ist es ja so, na, da setzen wir halt jetzt SS7 erstmal durch SS7 over IP und irgendwann ist ja die Idee sozusagen auch auf SS7 komplett zu verzichten. Das sehe ich ja ehrlich gesagt nicht so aus dem, was du mir so beschrieben hast. Wenn man sich anschaut, wie abgehangen diese Technologie ist und wie lang es die schon gibt.
Naja, irgendwann kommt immer die nächste Generation bei Technologien.
Ja gut, aber es ist auch selten ein revolutionärer Schillerit. Also ich meine, dass da jetzt jemand einen Hebel umlegt und dann ist nur noch IP und SIP.
Aber es gibt halt natürlich jetzt inzwischen schon längst Standards, die halt so definieren, wie man SIP auf SS7 umsetzt und umgekehrt. Und so dementsprechend kann das halt jeder in seiner eigenen Geschwindigkeit machen und auch die Netze teilweise migrieren erst mal und so eine Sachen. Und kommen wird das auf jeden Fall.
Und dann? Dann ist der Berufsaufbau langsamer? Oder ich meine es kann ja auch sein, dass alles gut wird dadurch.
Theoretisch kann das sein, ja. Also wie gesagt, diese erste Welle ist ziemlich in die Hose gegangen. Aber man muss halt bestimmte Dinge beachten. Also es muss halt auf deinem Internet-Link zu Hause, muss halt Kapazität reserviert sein, dass immer ein Sprachcall aufgebaut werden kann oder auch zwei oder drei. Das ist ja nicht viel Bandbreite. Das muss halt zuverlässiger werden zu Hause. Und auch das Equipment in den DSLAMs oder wie auch immer dann die aktuelle Internet Access Technologie ist die vorherherrschende, muss halt zuverlässiger werden. Und ich meine, das passiert ja alles. Also mit der Zeit wird das ja immer weiter getestet. Und auch die Hersteller und die Netzbetreiber lernen ja immer weiter dazu. Ob das Ganze dann letztlich zu einem besseren oder schlechteren Telefonnetz führt, ist natürlich so eine Frage. Wobei man natürlich auch sehen muss, dass das Telefonnetz als solches ja rapide an Bedeutung abnimmt. Also ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber mein Callvolumen ist in den letzten Jahren massiv gesunken. Einfach so, man hat jetzt halt Instant-Messaging und E-Mails und Chats und so weiter.
Und Twitter.
Twitter, genau. Und jemandem irgendwie mal eben im Jabber eine Nachricht zu schicken, ist halt längst nicht so...
Teuer wie eine SMS.
Ja und auch längst nicht so dringt, nicht so in die Privatsphäre ein wie gleich anzurufen. So häufig ist es dann sogar inzwischen schon so, dass man Anrufe erstmal irgendwie via Instant-Messaging vorbereitet und so und sagt, irgendwann hast du mal eine Minute Zeit.
Dann rufe ich mal an.
Genau und so eine Geschichten halt. Und dementsprechend ist halt die Frage, was für eine Bedeutung das Telefonnetz als solches hat, beziehungsweise das Telefonnetz als solches wird halt aufgelöst. Das geht dann halt im IP-Netz auf und es wird natürlich weiterhin Sprachtelefonie geben, aber das wird dann halt nur noch ein kleiner Teil dessen sein.
Aber wenn jetzt das Telefonnetz IP wird, reden wir dann von irgendeinem IP-Netz oder reden wir vom Internetz?
Naja, also die Netzbetreiber werden natürlich, oder sagen wir werden hoffentlich, ihr eigenes Intranetz dafür haben, ihr eigenes Backbone-Netz, was halt nur auf IP-Protokoll umgestellt wird.
Ja, aber in dem Moment, wo jetzt andere kleine Anbieter damit interfacen sollen, müssen sie ja natürlich zwangsläufig über das Internet an dieselbe Infrastruktur ran.
Ja, da gibt es halt Übergabepunkte.
Ja gut, aber das heißt, es sind schon Systeme, die über das Internet erreichbar sind, die heute nicht über das Internet erreichbar sind. Also jetzt sind sie es schon, in dem Folge, was du gesagt hast, dass man jetzt eben auch schon SS7 über IP sprechen kann, gibt es das so. Aber dann wird das sozusagen noch präsenter. Was ich mich jetzt aber eigentlich frage ist, wenn das jetzt so Next Generation ist, heißt das, dass sie dann IPv6 machen oder bauen die sich jetzt sozusagen noch ein Last Generation IPv4-Netzwerk auf?
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also ich weiß, dass irgendwie die Netzbetreiber, die derzeit Next Generation Networks betreiben, die machen v4.
Das klingt ja wirklich sehr nach Next Generation.
Genau, weil das Equipment der Hersteller, glaube ich, auch noch nicht durchgängig v6 macht und so.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht nachvollziehbar, weil es natürlich auch noch ein Bildungsaspekt ist. Und natürlich, die Software muss auch erst mal in diese Richtung gehen. Aber grundsätzlich, insbesondere im Hinblick auf Verschlüsselung oder ähnliche Aspekte, wäre es sicherlich sinnvoll, wenn dort auch IPv6 gemacht wird. Aber das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Frage, ob IPv6 überhaupt in absehbarer Zeit reinkommt. Und bevor ihr jetzt wieder eine E-Mail schickt, so ja, ja, IPv6 ist hier auch schon auf meiner Themenliste kommt. Du bist aber nicht so begeistert davon.
Ich persönlich bin davon nicht begeistert, weil ich bin halt Telefonfreak und ich...
Du hast es immer genossen, dass das eine Netz mit dem anderen Netz so nichts zu tun hatte, erstmal, ne?
Naja, und vor allen Dingen, also das ist halt schön einfach dedizierte 64-Kilo-Bit-Sprachverbindungen von einem Ende zum anderen zu haben.
Isochrone Kommunikation.
Genau. So geringe Latenz. Das ist natürlich auch noch so ein Problem. Latenz steigt halt irgendwie, wenn das durch Alphi geht, in den meisten Fällen an. Und ja, das ist einfach... Ich glaube, Telefonie in dieser hohen Qualität, wie sie bei uns noch vor ein paar Jahren selbstverständlich war, werden wir wahrscheinlich nie wieder haben.
Aber was die Qualität betrifft, meine Eins hat sich im normalen Telefonnetz nie durchgesetzt, nämlich ein ein besserer Codec, also eine bessere Sprachqualität.
Das ist richtig. Aber irgendwie... Also ich persönlich... Also wahrscheinlich war einfach der Bedarf nicht hoch genug und ich persönlich habe es auch nie vermisst. Also ich fand halt, da sind immer alle Informationen rübergekommen, die rüberkommen sollten. Und ja, klar, das kann man dann natürlich anders machen. Man kann dann beliebige Codecs einsetzen, auch welche, die eine deutlich höhere Bandbreite haben und kann so die Sprachqualität verbessern. Und natürlich wird es so sein, dass man, wenn man jetzt einen High-Quality-Link haben will, ihn auch kriegen kann. Aber das wird nicht der Regelfall sein. Ich denke einfach, dass die Gesamtqualität halt abnehmen wird. Beziehungsweise das passiert ja schon gerade die ganzen letzten Jahre. Man merkt es halt irgendwie, insbesondere wenn man von einem Netz ins andere telefoniert, dass man teilweise plötzlich, und dann vielleicht noch Call-by-Call benutzt oder so, dass man teilweise plötzlich schlechte, rauschende Verbindungen hat, dass man irgendwie das Calls gedroppt werden, dass irgendwas nicht durchgestellt werden kann, dass man woanders rauskommt, als es eigentlich hingehen sollte. Und all so eine Geschichten. Das ist mir halt ein Graus.
Das erinnert mich gerade an so ein großes Werbeplakat, was ich in Kanada gesehen habe von dem dort vorherrschenden Mobilfunkanbieter Rogers. Sie werben damit Less Dropped Calls.
Genau.
Das lässt wahrscheinlich schon mal so ein bisschen erahnen, in welche Richtung das geht, dass irgendwie jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr mit qualitativen Pluspunkten geworben wird, sondern nur mit... Ja, hier gibt es weniger Minus.
Genau. Ich meine, deshalb hatte ich vorhin auch gesagt, in Deutschland oder Westeuropa, also in den USA, ist das mit dem Telefonenetz ja schon immer so eine Sache gewesen. Ich meine, Rogers ist jetzt Kanada, aber da war es... Die hatten da ja sehr ähnliche Infrastruktur wie in den USA oder haben sehr ähnliche Infrastruktur wie in den USA. Also, das mit der Qualität war da irgendwie schon immer nicht so weit her.
Also, ich meine, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es schon so ist, dass die Leute auch bereit sind, zumindest ein Stück weit dieser Qualität, die sie gewohnt sind, auch zu opfern, wenn es dafür andere Vorteile gibt. Sei es, dass es billiger ist, sei es, dass es mehr Flexibilität bietet.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich bin da halt nostalgiker.
Ja, klar. Ich kann das auch nachvollziehen. Ich bin da eigentlich auch nostalgiker. Ich mag auch so dieses schöne, hammermäßige, irgendwie isochrone, einfach, das ist halt einfach, gerade diese Sache mit der Latenz, da ist man als Podcaster ja auch nochmal doppelt hinterher. Gerade wenn ich jetzt darüber nachdenke, dass man irgendwie so Fernverbindungen hat. Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite, und das ist jetzt eigentlich das, worauf ich hinaus wollte, wären also jetzt die Telefonnetze, die ja immer so ein technisches Alternativmodell hatten zur Sprachübertragung im Vergleich zu dem Internet, sich im Prinzip auch auf Internettechnologie einlassen und damit alle Vor-, aber auch eben alle Nachteile sich damit einfangen. Dann beschwören sie ja im Prinzip auch eine vollständig neue Konkurrenzsituation auf gegenüber Lösungen, die jetzt Software-only sind, zum Beispiel auf dem Computer oder auf irgendwelchen dedizierten Geräten, die rauskommen können. Sprich, Voice-over-IP ist ja derzeit eher so ein, naja, man nimmt es, wenn es halt wirklich über das normale Telefon zu kompliziert oder viel zu teuer ist. So, dann geht man irgendwie auf Voice-over-IP, hat aber dann natürlich auch viele andere lustige Vorteile, dass es sich mit Chat zum Beispiel wunderbar verbinden lässt, wenn man jetzt sowas wie Skype nimmt. Das hat ja auch seine Vorteile und man kann da irgendwie auch mal eine Datei draufdraggen. Wenn also jetzt die normalen Telefonnetze quasi ihre Vorteile der schnellen Verbindungsaufbau, so den zuverlässigen Sprachqualität einbüßen, sozusagen sich auf den Level von Voice-over-IP-Computer-Anwendung runterlassen, ist das dann nicht eigentlich die große Chance für die Computer vollständig abzuheben und dann auch die Dienste Telefon mit zu übernehmen?
Klar. Also das wird natürlich, ich meine, das konvergiert ja eh alles so ein bisschen. Und man hat ja so, was man jetzt heutzutage als Mobiltelefon in der Tasche hat, das ist ja im Prinzip eh nur noch ein Computer, der halt irgendwie ein Mobilfunkinterface hat und meistens dann auch noch ein WLAN-Interface. Und so, und über das WLAN-Interface kann man dann häufig auch schon Voice-over-IP machen und so eine Geschichten. Und letztlich wird sich das halt so, einfach das Telefon, das Telefon an sich wird halt, wird halt denke ich einfach aufgehen in diesen IP-Anwendungen, die es halt so gibt.
Und das heißt, dass auch das Mobiltelefon in absehbarer Zeit seine Sprache über IP macht? Ist das denn schon greifbar?
O2 hat sein gesamtes Backbone neulich auf IP umgestellt. Und deshalb haben wir vielleicht irgendwie einigen, also neulich ist gut, das war glaube ich im Oktober, November oder so.
2008.
Ja. Wo dann...
Chaosradio Express wird ja auch noch in 50 Jahren gehört, müssen wir das auch mal erwähnen.
Genau. Wo dann erstmal eine Zeit lang irgendwie jede Menge Dropped-Calls waren und irgendwie komische Verbindungen und rauschende Verbindungen und so ganz haben sie es irgendwie immer noch nicht im Griff. Aber ja, so klar wird das auch irgendwann kommen, dass man halt nur noch über IP telefoniert, auch vom Mobiltelefon aus.
Und du meinst, dass es da auch zu machen mit den Latenzen und so?
Ja, wenn du dir halt anguckst, zum Beispiel HSDP-A hat ja eine deutlich, also die schnelle Datenübertragung hat ja schon mal eine deutlich geringere Latenz, als man so von GPRS kennt.
Ich hab das noch nicht so, also ich meine, das ist ja nicht nur eine Frage von DPA, sondern dann auch eben von UPA. Man muss ja auch schnell hochpumpen beim Telefonieren. Also das gilt dann aber auch dafür.
Genau, richtig. So, und also das ist jetzt noch nicht...
Aber reicht das schon aus? Ich meine, ist jetzt...
Keine Ahnung. Also das ist jetzt... Es gibt halt auch schon Leute, die machen halt Voice-over-IP über UMTS, also über HSDP-A und HSUPA und so. Und sagen halt, das ist prima, mir wäre die Latenz da zu hoch. Aber natürlich, wenn es irgendwie gerade nicht anders geht, kann man darüber auch telefonieren. Und da wird natürlich dran gearbeitet werden, weil so eine bestimmte Latenz hält man halt... Die merkt man halt nicht. Und ab einem bestimmten Punkt fängt es dann halt an, echt unangenehm zu werden, dass man sich gegenseitig ins Wort fällt und so eine komische Geschichte. Und das muss natürlich verhindert werden. Also so eine ganz offensichtliche Service-Regression wird es halt, denke ich, mal nicht geben.
Weil da ist dann nämlich auch die Grenze erreicht.
Genau. Weil ich meine, jetzt kommt ja schon... Jetzt haben wir im Augenblick Mobilfunknetze der dritten Generation und beziehungsweise wird jetzt halt schon wieder von der dreieinhalbten Generation geredet, was HSDPA und HSUPA angeht. Und dann kommen jetzt als nächstes die vierte Generation, Long-Term-Evolution und die sollen natürlich wieder deutlich schneller und deutlich geringere Latenz und so weiter haben.
Also sozusagen die nächste Stufe nach UMTS, HSDPA und HSUPA.
Genau.
Welche Generation haben wir da jetzt?
Jetzt ist die dreieinhalbte.
Die dreieinhalbte, also das schnelle HSUPA und das schnelle HSDPA.
Genau, also beziehungsweise so ein normales UMTS ist halt dritte Generation und HSDPA und HSUPA sind halt Generation 3,5.
Okay, aber die gibst du dann auch wieder in zwei Abstufungen mit irgendwie doppelt so schnell.
Du meinst HSDPA und HSUPA?
Ja, gibt es doch irgendwie. Also die erste Ausbaustufe war doch 3,6 Megabit und das heißt...
1,8 ging es los.
1,8?
Genau.
Ah, was hast du denn auch schon in der dritten Stufe? Alles klar. Also 1,8, 3,6, 2...
Ja, das war schon von Anfang an definiert. Es gibt dann jetzt inzwischen allerdings HSPA Plus. Und das ist natürlich alles immer so eine Sache mit diesen Nummern, ob man da jetzt sagt, irgendwie das ist jetzt 3,75, so. Also zum Beispiel Edge, also der GSM, der schnellere GSM-Datenübertragungsstandard gilt halt als Generation 2,75. Also es wird dann halt irgendwann ein bisschen unsinnig.
Aber ich meine, also gibt es... HSPA ist jetzt so ein Sammelbegriff für alles, was schnell ist im OTS-Netz.
High-Speed Packet Access Plus.
Genau.
Ist dann halt irgendwie bis, ich glaube, 28,8 Megabit.
Im Download.
Und im Upload? Weiß ich gerade nicht. So. Aber das ist halt auch noch so ein Äckchen weit weg.
28 Megabit.
Megabit.
Wo muss ich unterschreien?
Es gibt jetzt gerade, glaube ich, die ersten Testnetze.
Erstaunlich, nicht? Also was da noch geht, das dürfte ja auch diesem Festnetzanschluss, dem Internetanschluss, auch nochmal ordentlich Konkurrenz machen.
Das ist halt auch der Plan der Telekommunikations-, der Netzbetreiber, dass sie halt irgendwie, ich meine, die werden halt eh einfach immer mehr zu IP-Paket verschiebern.
Und Mobilfunkanbietern.
Genau. Und die Mobilfunkanbieter werden auch immer mehr zu IP-Paket verschiebern. Und deshalb wollen die halt nicht noch so extra fette Infrastruktur von vor 20 Jahren rumstehen haben, auch wenn sie halt die viel bessere Qualität liefert.
Dann hoffen wir mal, dass sie sich der Internetkultur auch noch ein bisschen annähern und nicht so komische Bezeichnungen wie Global Title für ihre Telefonnummern verwenden. Wir werden es sehen. Ja, Tobias, haben wir es?
Ich denke mal so weit.
Ich denke auch. Ja, das war das Update zur ersten Sendung über digitale Telefonnetze. Jetzt war das quasi der Teil 2. Mal gucken. Ich glaube, da ist noch eine Menge zu holen für weitere Teile. Aber dann machen wir jetzt hier erst mal Schluss. Das war es. Chaosradio Express 110. Der Notruf fällt vielleicht doch nicht so schlimm aus, auch wenn Tobias wie auch mir seine niedrige Latenz doch teuer und lieb ist. Mal schauen, wie es weitergeht mit den Telefonnetzen. Auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr darüber nachdenkt, euch eine neue Telefonleitung zuzulegen, solltet ihr vielleicht zwei- oder dreimal nachfragen, was euch denn dann wirklich an die Wand geschraubt wird. Sollte das für euch wichtig sein?
Und in dem Zuge kann man natürlich auch noch mal sagen, apropos Notrufsendung, gerade bei NGN-Anschlüssen ist natürlich die Sache mit dem Notruf auch immer noch mal so ein Problem. Also wenn man halt plötzlich nicht telefonieren kann oder das ist verdammt dringend so, dann hat man da im Zweifelsfalle halt auch noch ein Problem.
Das stimmt. Sind die nicht sogar verpflichtet dafür?
Genau, sie sind verpflichtet, irgendwie Notrufe durchzustellen. Aber wenn jetzt irgendwie du die Feuerwehr anrufen willst, weil es brennt und deshalb ist bei dir schnell Strom ausgefallen und du kannst einfach nicht telefonieren, weil einfach die Leitung nicht mehr steht, dann ist das halt, bringt die Verpflichtung auch nichts mehr.
Hm, das stimmt. Tja, das sind immer die Details, die man bedenken muss. Ja, das war's. Dann sagen wir schön ordentlich Tschüss zu den Hörern.
Tschüss.
Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.